so how have you been keeping up speaking
of this is us do you all have
i know that you get in these casts
especially these really success ones
are on there for seasons like have you
all been able to catch up at all have
you all zoomed at all or done anything
yeah so we have done the zoom we have
zoomed
out um and it was so sweet because
justin hartley
um who plays kevin is like he's the one
that's like
hey guys do you want to zoom and we're
like oh
like and that's just justin like he's
not just like a handsome guy who's super
talented like he has the biggest heart
and so it was so cute that he's the one
that wanted to arrange it so
um and then chris arranged you know the
actual appointment time and called it
the miguel rivas
fan club which john huertas plays miguel
who and everyone always like no one
likes miguel
john is the best sport about it all
because everybody just you know makes a
joke about it but um yeah it's a lot of
fun we just get to sort of
see each other which is nice it's like
the phone calls aren't quite enough and
the text chats weren't no
getting to see each other like any kind
of zoomer face time or i agree
i mean can you imagine what this would
be like without it
without seeing people like and just on a
phone like you know in the kitchen with
the like roseanne phone line that's like
10 feet long um yeah that would kill me
yeah
yeah it wouldn't be good that's for sure
so grateful for technology
yeah no no me too um so who of your this
is us
seem to be having the best time in
quarantine like when y'all talked who's
like living their best life
i think it really me i have to be honest
i really like being at home
you don't have kids right now so that's
oh there you go that's why
you know what i'm telling you that
you're having the best time
i don't know about everybody else but
that's i love i love actually getting to
have the
the time i'm especially like you know
recently i've been waking up every
morning coloring with them and it's like
a lot of
kind of me time with them and i've loved
that but at the same time it's like oh
my gosh i really want to go to a dinner
with adults and just talk about adult
things
so yeah i mean i feel frustrated because
he and ryan
he and his wife are you know obviously
teaching their two sons
and he's like man it's like i gotta i
gotta run guys i got i gotta start class
i gotta do this we
to do that and my god i know i don't
i don't listen i can barely keep a
succulent alive that i started
i think they're like the easiest plants
to keep alive
they don't need anything i know that's
amazing that's why you're my favorite
human
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going